don't go into the new year
being the exact same person you were
last year
doing the exact same things that you did
this past year won't get you to where
you want to go aka you gotta level up
and it might be hard to do and you might
need to do things that you're not
accustomed to doing you might need to
try a little harder wake up a little
earlier do a little better read a little
more whatever it is but leveling up and
i said pat thank you man that's a great
message and let me um
let me revisit that after i get drunk on
new year
and i was like racing double reading
this segment oh my god this ain't the
time no but i do appreciate that but
that's sort of the the point here of
this message here what's my point most
people are focused on jeff bezos being
sort of like a knockoff pitbull you're
making your jokes look at this guy this
goofy little shirt and right you know
the girlfriend and the song the glasses
whatever disco but the message that he's
basically saying is take stock and focus
on your personal growth
and reinvent yourself and it's
essentially the same
message that pat gave to me is like
don't be the exact same person you were
last year or the year before the year
after that now pat's been very explicit
about this on the pbd podcast about
one years one year he was uh
i think on new year's and he told the
story about he's sitting in a car with
with his buddy he had no money they got
water from in and out they got sugar
packets and they got some lemons and
they shook it up made lemonade and he
goes damn i am so broke i can't even
afford lemonade i gotta make my own
ghetto rigged version of lemonade
i gotta get better and every year
clearly the guy has gotten better so
that's my message it's a new year you
know you could do the lip service thing
i'm going to get better i'm going to try
harder i'm going to lose weight i'm
going to make more whatever it is
but are you actually doing it and are
you who's holding you accountable like i
talked about with the beginning of the
show
with money in personal finance 50
knowledge right 50 i know i need to do
better i know i need to eat healthier i
know i need to work out the other 50 is
behavioral who the hell is actually
holding you accountable to do that and
if it's not yourself maybe it's someone
like pbd or leader in your life
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken